[Music]
hello welcome to another talk welcome to
modern Android development I should
point out before we start that this Sun
is a lot brighter than I am so yeah so
we can either put on the glasses and not
see the slides or don't put on the
glasses and not see anything so so
that's gonna be fun we'll see how this
goes today welcome to modern Android
development I'm Chet Haase from the
Android toolkit team and then we'll
amongee from the android framework team
so there's something and we're gonna
talk about a bunch of stuff that you
probably already know but it occurred to
us that we have given you advice and
information about how to develop good
apps for Android over the years and that
information has changed over the years
as we've introduced new capabilities new
API is new performance on the platform
all kinds of things and so it's a little
confusing you could go search for
information even on some of our Doc's
site and maybe get information that
doesn't really apply to a lot of
situations currently so we wanted to
wrap it all together and say here's our
current 2018 view of the important
things to think about Android this 10
year old 10 years old this year and the
electorate said a lot of outdated
information sometimes you know I see
blogs on Stack Overflow someone being
really mad about something that we said
10 years ago don't be mad it's ok things
change things evolve well it's not
because we hate to is that because if we
were wrong it's because it was a
different time different needs different
devices so we're going to talk about
some of that just to make sure you
understand the difference between the
modern way of doing thing and the old
way of doing thing we have a slight hint
on the slides so some of the sides are
going to look like this so let us begin
so let's take a look at a timeline this
is sort of all the you know history of
Android over time so 1.8 1.0 came out in
2008 and then apparently we didn't do
much for several years and I don't know
what was going on there I just couldn't
think of the things to put in there
optimize optimize optimize well then the
Android studio came out what
according to the web we were busy
building bad api's apparently those
weren't the ones you wanted so we've
worked better at that over the years so
Android studio came out so we changed
from eclipse in the Android studio where
now we were building in Richard
capabilities then we could at the time
art came out it was let's see it was off
by default in KitKat and it was the only
runtime in lollipop this is huge as
you'll see in some of our
recommendations there because it really
has changed over time the way we look at
the way you should write your code prior
dalvik information does not necessarily
apply in an art world recyclerview was
released important because it was a
better version of ListView with more
flexibility but also we started
releasing components in the support
library disconnected from platform
releases which means you could use these
new capabilities in your applications
across all the releases that you cared
about little while later we had
constraint layout built into Android
studio a richer way of actually
designing your api's as opposed to the
rich way of typing XML directly Kotlin I
think that came out last year I don't
know some IO conference or something
architecture components these were
announced last year 1-0 in the fall new
way of doing things where we are trying
to solve or at least help with a lot of
complex problems with Android and taking
feedback from the community and
iterating on that to create developer
API is that make things easier for you
that is the whole goal studio profilers
so much richer way for actually figuring
out what the performance metrics are for
your application KTX the extension
library that came out a couple of months
ago for Kotlin and recently the paging
library came out went 1-0 just this week
so this is sort of a scope of some of
the things that have happened over time
I'm pretty sure there was more going on
between 2008 and 2013 I just can't
remember what it was all right we're
gonna start with tools here's a tool
that you may know how many of you have
used this tool hard here oh that's
pretty good and not everyone there was
so that was our tool called Harkey or it
was part of the sdk twister stand-alone
application there was actually another
version before that one that was the one
our dealer wrote in the weekend
because I needed the bugging tool to
optimize the platform and for some
reason we started shipping it in the SDK
it wasn't the fastest tool it wasn't the
prettiest tool actually this one was
built by someone who funnily enough
we're spending a lot of time actually
sleeping at their desk that was very
interesting never used the technique
before didn't quite work so now we
replaced it with something much better
called layout inspector it's part of
Android studio one of the nice benefits
that you can open multiple inspections
at once it's a lot faster so if you
haven't used that tool go use it it's a
very easy way to analyze your Harkey and
you know debug various things like
padding and margin and you know even
performance sometimes if you have too
many views that overlap each other
here's another one that's the old way of
profiling the code so that was called
trace view so trace view is a tool that
already existed when I joined the
Android team in 2007 so it's been around
for quite a while here we see it in
action inside of Eclipse it used to be
its own standalone tool so one of the
issues that we had with trace with the
original version was an instrumented
profiler so there was a lot of overhead
it was running on every method that was
invoked it was running in interpreted
mode and so you couldn't really trust
the number so when he said you know this
method took three milliseconds that
wasn't true the method actually was a
lot faster than that and the only thing
you could do is compare the relative
time between different methods and even
that was difficult because if a method
was invoking native code native code was
not affected so any method in working
native code was skewed because you know
numbers projects also wrong over the
years we added sampling for funding to
the stool but so it was very difficult
to use only a few of us even were using
it internally because it wasn't that
great a few later thankfully we
introduced systrace so the big benefit
of systrace of a tracer is that it gives
you a comprehensive view of the entire
system trace view tells you how much
time you're spending in on every line of
code inside your application basically
but sometimes performance issues come
from somewhere else in the system maybe
you're blocked on something that's in a
different process so this trace gives
you that view that you needed before
that were completely in the blind and
now we have
fellows that have been introduced in
Android studio I think they're part of
three point two or three point one I
don't remember but if you go to the to
the profile tab you're going to see a
real-time graph of the CPU usage of your
application and the memory usage of your
application and if you double-click on
the CPU graph you're going to get to
that view looks very similar to trace
you again it's a lot faster and it lets
you do native code profiling
instrumented profiling sampling for
fighting and even systrace so this is
the tool that you should be using from
now on and this is what the produce
graphs look like so we have now a
believe three graph four graphs we have
the the CPU one the memory one the
network one and the energy one I've
never used the network one because I'm
not sure what servers are for but I'm
sure you guys understand that and you'll
make good use of it and that's what it
looks like when you when you enter the
the CPU profiler so you get a flame
graph you have different ways of
analyzing the data the one I like is the
flame graph it's going to colorize all
the function calls with the different
colors depending on how much time they
take so anything that shows in red
shades or dark orange are the
bottlenecks inside your application so
very easy way to drill down and then
inside your application identify the
bottlenecks this is the native profiler
it's available starting on android 8.0
so in the Oreo or her to be able to run
it and I mentioned briefly the new
memory profiler so to do memory tracking
we used to use this tool called DDMS
again it was a standalone tool it was
built on the Eclipse platform it was a
little difficult to use Kristin was not
part of the idea at some point we added
it back in the idea and I was pretty
much the only good way you could see
whether or not we're allocating memory
in the wrong places for instance when
you're doing drawing or doing layout or
touch handling and now it's part of
again studio so when you see this graph
that shows you in real time the memory
usage you can even see like the
different buckets so it's gonna tell you
how much you're using on your Java heap
or how much native memory you're using a
how much graphics memory you using so
you can pinpoint where the plan is
coming from you can also create a slice
as you see on-screen and is going to
show you all the allocations during that
time you can see the stack traces you
can fold the references you don't have
to dump
to do damage profile converted using
edge popcorn you don't have to run j-hat
and see this horrible looking web UI
that you used to have to use it doesn't
do everything yet so sometimes you still
have to go to J hat but it's a very good
way to get sorry if you have memory
issues inside your application layout
design used to be like this it's hard to
call a design and it's interesting
because when Android came out it was
very hard to convince everyone to move
to XML remember a lot of angry
developers really wanted to write Java
code to build a UI and now we've given
you this so this is the constraint
layout the visual editor and now we have
a lot of angry developers who would love
to use only XML and not the visual tool
so I guess we have to invent something
new just as a decoy to make you start
using this one I think the only constant
is that engineers will be unhappy with
whatever new option you give them
especially the French and if you went to
the if you went to the wedding tools
talk you've seen a sneak peek of a new
tool for motion layout to create
animations using constantly out Nicola
and John are going to show that again I
think tomorrow Thursday so go find that
talk and so we want to make it clear
that this visual designer is only the
beginning there's so much more we can do
we haven't had time to build everything
yet but this new motion layout editor is
one is the next step and you know
building animations with visual feedback
real-time visual feedback is of what
make sure than using XML runtime in
language said sure so dalvik don't be so
sad
well that was awesome for doing what it
was designed to do which was it was
optimized for space when the g1 came out
it had 192 Meg's 48 of which well 64 a
small portion was a very small amount of
memory was actually available for
applications to use so dalvik could not
as a runtime take up a bunch of memory
for itself for all the the heap and
where it needed to store things so that
meant that as devices got better as
memory got larger it didn't necessarily
have the capabilities to optimize in the
wholesale way that we needed to at some
point they basically started from
scratch on the art
time that as we said came out in KitKat
and was default in lollipop but back in
the dalvik days we basically had
recommendations that came from that
because of things like allocations being
really expensive it had to walk the heap
and find a place to put this thing and
the heap got fragmented over time which
meant that even if it had a bunch of
space there it didn't necessarily have a
lot of contiguous space in which to find
a place to put that object and then
collections were also really expensive
you ended up you would allocate things
over time and then eventually it is
going to run out of memory and when it
does that when you're in the middle of
an animation you're on the UI thread and
it says I need to allocate space for a
bitmap can't find the space better run a
GC you're probably going to lose two or
three frames just because dalvik needed
to actually collect all the items
without references anymore so some of
the recommendations we had were
basically avoid allocating things
whenever you can that's certainly the
way that we live life inside the
framework because we are your inner loop
but we also recommended that application
developers do that one of the
recommendations that I believe the
community has seen batted around was
don't use a news write because they are
it turns out on a new structure the
class structure is a whole lot bigger
than an in table jekt right and we use
insult over the place because we try to
minimize the amount of memory we're
taking out and we also try to minimize
the amount of time we're creating a new
object as opposed to passing primitive
types around we also said that primitive
types are cool
insert cool floats are cool capital I
integer not so cool also what's not cool
is auto boxing so when you're using
standard collection classes if you have
a bunch of information stored in these
primitive types and they're being auto
box in and out or if you're using other
patterns and approaches that cause these
things to get created into objects you
would see in the tools that we had like
allocation tracker at the time the you'd
be auto boxing and causing allocations
along the fly and then eventually GC
kicks in and you hate yourself just a
little bit more so modern world we now
have art it is optimized for performance
it was created from the ground up not to
optimize for memory but to optimize for
performance and this is performance in
terms of met
call stuff but it's also optimized for
allocations and collections way faster
allocations and collections for a few
different reasons one of those is it has
a set aside for large objects so instead
of putting everything in the same heap
and then having to find space for large
objects amidst all the tiny ones it puts
all the bitmaps in a separate heap all
the large objects overall it's way
easier to find information I find space
for those large objects and then the
small objects go in the separate heap
also really cool it candy fragments -
all of it could not defragment so it
would allocate over time and eventually
there wasn't enough space for that thing
you needed so you would get these
obscure error messages where it said
that it couldn't find a megabyte because
there's only 48 megabytes free doesn't
make a lot of sense until you realize
well it's probably that the heap is
fragment and we can't really do much
about that now we can in our 2d
fragments that heap in an earlier
release it would be fragment when the
application was in the background now we
can actually defragment when the
applications in the foreground as well
so way better so the recommendation we
have now are go ahead and allocate when
necessary it's okay in fact if you use a
noobs I don't care go ahead
apparently you do care so I hope you
enjoy them
we still as a rule tend to not use them
in a lot of framework Odin api's they
are they are there sometimes but as I
said we are still the inner loop so we
tend to be way more conservative than
you necessarily need to be in your
application code use appropriate types
I still think primitive types are really
cool but you know what if you need to
use a collection with an object type
that's okay but be aware that these
phones are still constrained devices
memory may not be you know 48 or 64
Meg's available but it is still being
shared with everything else you being
used being run on that system also
batteries are really important it's
important to let that battery last as
long as possible so if you're constantly
doing things all the time if you're
constantly generating garbage and
collecting it sure art is a lot faster
at that but art still has to do the work
of actually allocating and collecting
and all of that stuff uses powers so
it's still good to remember that the
battery uses power and that maybe you
should be conservative on what you're
trying to do and also like the framework
be aware of the inner loop bottlenecks
don't do things in a tight loop that may
cause performance problems so when
Android was started the team decided to
go with the Java programming language to
create applications and there were many
reasons for that the main one was it was
an extremely popular language there were
millions of developers who knew how to
use this language
there were many excellent and free tools
so you know it was really helpful for
the quick adoption of the Android
platform over time we have been
sometimes a little bit slow at adopting
new versions of the language we recently
started supporting the Java programming
language version 1.8 I think they are
reaching ten at one point ten but it
served us for many years
last year thankfully we announced full
support for the couplet programming
language how many of you are using it
right now all right keep him up 1 2 3
almost everyone it was dead well more
than 5 we'll skip a few side so we
announced it last year in 2017 we're
working in close collaboration with
JetBrains
we're making sure that our tools work
work well of Catalan and it makes
that we have access to the features we
need overall we like it because it makes
code more enjoyable to read and to write
and we spend so much time reading and
writing code that it does matter so have
a few examples here they're gonna be
hard to read but it's okay because you
all know how to write cut line those
examples are taken from the Kathleen
extensions so I'm going to go over them
really quickly I like named parameters
you don't have to create multiple other
loads of methods or builders all the
time you can inline functions which is
really useful when you create extensions
or even when you create graphics code
for instance we saw that operators you
can overload operators you should be you
know careful with that you can use this
quite a bit and I've done this myself
one since I created an infix operator
called axe because it looks like the
cross-product for vectors don't do that
it's a terrible idea I put it on github
because it's a terrible idea
you can do this structuring assignment
so when you have a POJO you create
methods called component 1 2 3 etc then
you can do more you can do multiple
assignments in one line of code so this
is an example again from Kathleen Katie
Android Katie axe where we dis structure
an integer so you don't have to do
shifting and masking of bytes and
integers we have data classes very easy
way to create all those gathers and to
string and calls and ash code so you
don't have to and you don't even have to
type the shortcut to tell IntelliJ to do
it for you that's 2 level of laziness
that we reached with Kathleen so that's
fantastic and finally yes I just want to
call out some of the things that to me
make make cotton so appealing is very
smart design decisions they've made in
the language and one of them for
instance is when a lambda is the last
parameter of a function they have this
special syntax that you can use you'll
have to pass the lambda as a parameter
to the function you can just open the
curly braces and put your code right
there it looks and feels a lot more
natural so one of the things we're doing
now when we design a new API is in the
platform starting with Android P we make
sure that our Java API is follow these
conventions when we have a single
abstract method interface we make sure
that the parameter that use this
interface goes at the end of the list of
parameters so that cutting developers
can you know benefit
from this particular feature in the
language and we're going to do more and
more of that in the support library in
all of our future api's so for those of
you who are not using cart in yet
project and contains both cotton and
Java you don't have to convert all your
application to cutting you can the next
class you're at your application can be
cutting or you can convert an existing
class we have a ton of lint checks is
there are things that are missing go to
out or is going to write it like pretty
much in front of you and commit it right
away it's kind of a machine when it
comes to trading lean checks check out
the Android extensions again there's a
talk by a Jack Wharton I think on
Thursday morning about it
it's going to talk about a lot of
interesting things we also created a
style guide so those of you who are
still using our Java guide I mean we
didn't really have one but if you're
following our source code you're pretty
perfect in your fields with em you're
gonna be happy to know that we're not
doing that anymore with cutting first
because we don't really like it and also
because you can't redo it because of the
properties syntax and cut in any way we
also have an interoperability guide so
if you're gonna be writing code that is
meant to be consumed by both Java
developers and cutting developers beets
that you're writing java code or cotton
code we have gets for you that explained
how you should be writing your IPS to
the of the they can be used in a natural
manner in both languages and those are
the guys that were following ourselves
for new ideas in the platform in the
support libraries let's talk about api's
first of all layouts and Android there
are a bunch of them but these are kind
of the major ones that people dealt with
over time first of all there was
absolute layout and you know it's so
easy to use why wouldn't you then you
just tell the view exactly where you
want it to be right linear layout you
can just nest those things as deeply as
you want to and get the exactly the UI
you're looking for frame layout it's
fine you know you can you squint at it
it's kind of like an absolute layout if
that's the best thing we can say about
it comply
grid layout turns out it's a little bit
complicated to use but you know we can
figure that out and it has a lot of
flexibility there and relative layout
we've heard that it's expensive is this
something we should be using or not so
the modern world here's how we think
about absolute layout
we just want to make it clear
[Applause]
the only reason that this is not
deprecated is because there is one
important class that subclass it is the
participate okay well we deprecated and
that's about as far as we can take
because webview is an absolute layout
sorry
don't use that hopefully you're not
linear layout it's actually fine to
still use especially for simple cases if
you're deeply deeply nesting then you're
deeply deeply wronged and there's a
better solution we get to it at the
bottom of the slide frame layout it's
also okay for simple use cases you need
to put that one thing in there with you
know appropriate padding and margins
that's kind of what the dirty secrets of
Furman out is that it's an absolute
layout in these guys use margins
correctly you're busy enough so close
but don't do that don't do that don't do
that a grid layout so it turns out that
it's it's really intended to be used
with tools except the problem was we
never actually wrote the tools so I
think we forgot probably not the best
layout to use for your situation unless
you're already wrapped your head around
it okay there may be better solutions
out there relative layout we believe
that constraint layout is in general a
better solution now we think of it as a
subset of the capabilities a relative
layout it has a lot of the same
capabilities of relative positioning of
children with respect to each other but
it has way more like relative
positioning to guidelines and some of
the new capabilities they've been
working on to consider what I like to
describe use construct notes these are
relative layout that's works and also
the best thing about it is it's tightly
integrated with the tool it was written
in tandem like by the same people with
the tool which means the design tool
works really well with that layout as
opposed to well they created the api's
and the tools sort of never caught up
that is not the case there we mentioned
2.0 it's not 2.0 yet I would say it's
too dotto soon so gusano I am what's up
into dotto that talk by John and Nicola
this week we'll go over some of that
stuff probably final thought on on
absolute layout just to make it clear so
we have a class in the UI toolkit called
adapter view it's the base class for a
number of widgets so list view grid view
in gallery and
all I mean they served us fine for many
many years they had a few issues they
were difficult to maintain
grid-view I think has not been used by
pretty much any app for quite a while
maybe for applications gallery is kind
of like a horizontal ListView and I'm
pretty sure it's been deprecated for a
long time and we haven't certainly been
looking at it for a while so I wouldn't
use it if I were you anyway oh it
doesn't work so you have some of the
issues so an adapter view has an adapter
and the adapter is the interface between
your data set and the view itself so one
of the things you can do in the adapter
is nullified view of any changes in the
data set the points that you can only
notify of course grant changes all you
can say is hey something has changed so
absurdly enough in this view we have a
lot of code that's trying to figure out
what has changed wouldn't be nice if you
could tell us because you probably know
well we built an API where you cannot
tell us so that's kind of done we also
used to tell you to follow this pattern
the view holder so the view holder and
you know it's one of those things where
I've seen a lot of people mad online
about the view holder because for
updates you have to write it was
actually extremely important I went back
and I looked at one of our old talks and
using the view holder pattern would give
you an extra 10 frames per second when
you were scrolling your list view on its
mobile g1 so it did matter a lot way
back then it's not as necessary anymore
but in the case of recycle you it's part
of the API so you cannot get it for free
anyway and funny animations animations
are possible with adapter views of
instance let's say you have a ListView
in an item disappeared from the data set
and you'd like the item to fade away and
the rest of the item to collapse and
close the gap you can do this with
ListView
all you need to do is write this little
bit of code Chet wrote a blog post about
it I think a few years ago that was one
of the ListView animations we had a
series of videos showing you how to do
different ones this is part of this part
of the code you only need to understand
the future observer and transient state
and measures and now to the animations
it was rather difficult so instead now
we have the recycler view thank thankful
so this is just a dumb application the
first time actually used a recycler view
was a couple months ago it was so much
easier that was really nice I was able
to create the different versions the
recycle view the nice
battery sacrifice that instead of
creating of having multiple widgets that
are effectively different layouts for
your data set you can specify a layout
for this for single recyclerview so this
is the same exact code with just
different layout managers for the
recycler I should point out too that all
of those words verdict were vertical but
you can actually have a horizontal
layout for years people asked us how to
do a horizontal OSB you just set a
rotation on the ListView and then you
have to intercept all the touch events
and rotate them and then you know
there's a few more ApS that you put in
you to override because anyway that was
easy
secret though the easiest way is simply
rotate your phone 90 degrees which has
gotten easier with some of the system UI
improvements anyway that's released so
and one of the nice things about recycle
view I mean there's so many things much
much better ways you know we have paging
and we have prefetching the API is nicer
you can change level managers you can
write on the out manager but also
animations they come for free so the
equipment have the code we just saw is
this and in particular with recycle you
what you get is fine grained changes so
you can tell us if an item was removed
what item was removed when an item was
added what I think was that it you can
tell us about phalanges of the of items
that I've changed or you can tell us
that everything has changed this is much
better for you and for us all right
fragments in the old days we heard that
fragments were really complicated and
also we would fix this thing so we
didn't necessarily have everything
correct or have all the api's that
people needed so we would put in
improvements and we put that into the
platform release and then applications
could only use that with devices on that
platform release and so the modern
device is don't use the platform version
we have since ported all of that code
and make all of the fixes in the sport
library and we have now deprecated
fragments in the core platform so don't
use them there use the support library
or now jetpack version of fragments we
are putting more goodness there so use
those and also we are making continuing
to make improvements there's a talk on
fragments this week tomorrow by Adam and
Ian tomorrow so please check that out to
hear more information about things that
we are doing as well as ways to use
fragments which should be a little bit
easier a major
one of those is the new navigation
controller so check that out it sort of
builds on fragments that doesn't depend
on them there is no dependency but it
does build on those capabilities for
creating and navigating between the
screens of your application activities
very closely related to fragments in the
old days basically Android applications
consisted of multiple activities that
was the application flow for all Android
applications we expected developers to
do this and developers did this when you
want to go from one sort of screen of
your app to another one you launch an
intent you get a new window there you
have some window animation to get you
there and there you are the new approach
is use single activities when you can it
turns out that's a much richer
experience for the user those window
animations they're well they're
animating but they're not doing anything
interesting they're not doing anything
that helps the user transition from one
state of the application to another
instead it's basically completely
separate windows that are coming into
view when you could actually use single
activity approaches to retain the same
chrome around the application white as
well have the same action bar with the
content switching out from underneath it
or use richer animations which are
possible with either the core platform
animations or fragment transactions
fragment animations so go ahead and use
an activity you may have situations in
your application where you have
different entry points especially if you
have a deep link that someone may come
into your application with then it's
appropriate to have separate activities
that is the way to expose that
information but otherwise try to use a
single activity fragments are not
necessary for single activity
applications but they can help with this
a lot especially with some of the recent
improvements there and the navigation
controller stuff to architecture so here
was the old advice a few years ago mm
okay
only 2016 so basically two years ago
Dianne Hackborn posted this on G+ we
usually get this question from
application developers where they will
ask us what application architecture
they should use in their application
and our answer is always we don't care
we are not you we don't know how your
application works we don't know the best
architecture for your application so
please make your own decision and then
there's usually a follow-up question of
yeah yeah I get that but which
architecture should I use so Diane
posted this to basically say this once
and for all we do not care the
components that we have in there the the
content providers the activities the
services these are system level
components they're not an architecture
around which you build your application
so please build the one that's
appropriate for your applications the
new advice is actually we're happy to
provide you some recommended
architecture because it turns out that
people would at least like some common
advice that makes sense and we believe
that we have that now specifically with
the architecture components we think
that we have an approach that makes a
lot of sense
we have api's that are easy to use and
you can build around those we are not
demanding that you use this please use
the architecture that makes sense to you
but we do have a core architecture that
we believe should work if you're
starting a new application if you have
new developers on your team it makes
sense one of the reasons that we worked
with Android architecture components was
to solve hard problems one of the
hardest problems was Android lifecycle
and our answer was all you need to do is
understand this diagram and memorize it
and someone externally did their own
version that diagram which looks like
this which is actually a lot easier to
understand if you look at it like this
so that's basically everything you need
to know and keep in your head at all
times so the problem would be you would
basically create a bunch of methods in
your activity so that you could track
and manage lifecycle you're handling
creation and starting and stopping and
resuming and pausing and you're probably
doing stuff in destroy as well you're
probably doing too much in oncreate
you're probably having race conditions
as well as the leaks and you're starting
your stop and you're probably doing that
in the pause and resume as well and
you're not exactly sure why you're
overriding on destroy but someone told
you you probably should so we'll do that
as well so in the meantime you actually
only know the lifecycle State if you
override those methods we didn't give
you a way to query that we know what it
is internally we're just not letting you
in on the sea
all right so there is no API for you to
query so you need to override all those
methods and then you end up chucking too
much code in there so too much logic
basically happening everywhere the new
approach is we have an object called a
lifecycle owner you can ask it for a
lifecycle object and then you can either
query the state if you want to know what
state a lifecycle you're in or you can
set an observer on it and then you can
get callbacks into this methods this
allows you to abstract it into a
separate place so you're not basically
bogging down activity code with all this
information but you're putting it where
it makes sense in your application
fortunately we override we subclass
lifecycle own or implement that in both
fragment and app compat activities so in
the support library please use these
those are lifecycle owners so basically
you can query them to get the lifecycle
and then go from there so we went from a
model where you would have activity with
basically all of this lifecycle
dependent logic in it to a model where
the activity can be much smaller take
that logic out abstract it into this
over the thing over there set a
lifecycle observer on it and get the
callbacks you want we have a similar
problem going on with views and data we
have an activity and then we have all
this information about the views in
there and then we have the data for the
views and we need to know when the data
changes and we need to also track the
lifecycle so we don't leak things or
call things at the wrong time so we just
end up having too much stuff there well
now you have this concept of a live data
and a view model where you can put that
stuff you can abstract it out of the
activity so you can put all that
information out there observe that stuff
so now in the activity you should really
have only information about views and a
reference to the view model and then put
all of that logic in the view model it's
using live data objects its handling
lifecycle on its own and you can observe
it way better way less buggy for data
our approach our our argument to you was
kind of well you you're on your own we
don't we don't manage your data do
whatever you want and there are lots of
database solutions out there we have
sequel light in the platform go ahead
and use it knock yourself out whatever
weird that we don't want to get into
that business the new approach is we
actually do offer something for data it
built on top of sequel Lite but it
actually offers build time verification
so you're not just sending these queries
down and then getting errors at runtime
but you can see this problem at build
time and integration with the live data
stuff that we saw earlier or you can be
on your own if you if you want to we're
not trying to take over your database
solution we're simply offering a better
local persistence story than we had
previously to make it easier for you the
overall diagram looks like this the only
new element here is this idea of
repository it's a pattern for basically
abstracting for where the data comes
from so if it comes from local or web
shouldn't matter to the rest of the
people that are querying it so it's kind
of nice to have an abstraction their
data paging so we had this thing called
cursor adapter it had some good elements
about it it did have support for a
database cursor that's nice but it was
specific to ListView and had basically
other problems with in efficiencies
paging sizes stuff like that
we had a sync list util which was more
useful but also was really inefficient
for doing things like web transactions
so we'd have a new model in modern
Android we have data paging the paging
library went 1-0 this week and there are
good things about it so it works with
recyclerview
it handles fine grains data changes this
is much more efficient uses background
threads very easily you can observe
changes so it's integrated with live
data but again we're not forcing this
architecture on you if you're using rx
Java - you can integrate with that very
easily as well and flexible data
fetching options so you can specify you
know the window size and when you want
to get these things there are of course
always trade-offs I find that the bad
thing about data paging is that the name
is rather boring graphics so when we
start the Android we only add the OpenGL
ES 1.0 we didn't even
we were doing everything with
software renderer that was an issue for
several years it was fast enough for the
ology devices it's only when we hit the
tablet form factor that started to
become an issue we used to do a lot of
nine batches and I'm sure some of you
have suffered through the creation the
nine patches or even worse trying to
explain your UI UX designer how to
create them like where do you put the
black dots which side would they go I
still don't know to this day text review
which refers you we touched on that on
in our previous talk basically there was
always this point of use the less
efficient texture view but that can
integrate better with the other views
that at least view animations or the use
surface view and managing bitmaps was
hard a lot of you built applications and
you were getting out of many are errors
because you're trying to create bitmaps
and you have to do caching and this is
difficult and our answer was basically
it's Tel Aviv so nowadays we have opened
the other 3.1 and 3.2 you have computers
you have Vulcan if you want to do low
level a graphics rendering we do a
hardware acceleration everywhere vector
drawables I've basically replaced most
of our drawables and bitmaps in
applications we have small applications
we don't want to support supporting
multiple densities is a lot easier you
don't need as many as matches as before
and something that we're now doing is
that we're working with you very often
develop application they were first turn
to us for solutions but when the
community that means you have been
building amazing libraries that we think
are the right answer that's the ones you
should be using so for instance glide of
Picasso or la di excelent at what they
do like you want to manage bitmap so if
you want to create crazy complex
animation with Lodi you should use those
we're not gonna you know spend them
we're creating something that already
exists out there and that we think is
very good at what it does so please go
use those libraries again nowadays you
should probably surface you in a text
review anymore it has outlived its time
and finally we used to tell you to
profile your code we used to tell you to
work whenever possible and to minimize
memory cousin consumption but now we
have better devices you know we have a
lot of course but a lot of RAM we have
been
language is a better runtime so instead
what you should be doing is providing
your code and avoiding work whenever
possible and also minimizing memory
consumption because it turns out that
devices are still constrained you need
to keep that in mind
battery life is critical and bandwidth
is precious and all of these contribute
to user experience so your user will
thank you if you are actually still
being conservative out these things and
getting the best performance for your
application that's appropriate we would
like to thank you and there's a
different way to say this and I think
we're done thank you
[Music]